Oh, hi, I didn't see you there. Sorry.
I brought the Burt Reynolds
play real close up. Tim Ferriss,
we're going to show you an exercise
that is called cathedral and it is very
useful for handstand practice or any type
of inversion practice and engaging the
musculature. That will be very
important for anything more advanced.
There are different ways to practice
handstands and of course one of the
limiting factors for a lot
of people is the risks.
The risks will get really grumpy,
the forums will get a really lit up,
the elbows would get really lit up.
So how do you practice more?
How do you add volume without
destroying these joints? Uh,
especially as a novice, there are
few ways you can go about doing it.
Some people will do,
they'll do posts like this where
they'll actually post on their forearms.
Other people will use something called
a feed up or a shoulder stand up,
basically looks like a padded toilet
seat and they stick their head through so
that they can place the weight on their
shoulders and then perform exercises.
But what if you don't have
any of this equipment? Well,
it turns out you can use a partner
for a very simple exercise,
relatively simple and there's
a progression. So Kipling,
my good friend here, uh,
at Kipling,
Kip,
l I n n on Instagram and everywhere else
is going to demonstrate what this looks
like and in effect I'm just supporting
her in a shoulder stand and I'll give
some commentary as we go through.
All right,
so
like,
so now as I place my hands
on basically taking the,
the palms and putting them to the point
where they feel like they're going to
slip,
but just before my hands
are very widely open,
like so.
And you'll elicit that Kipling's given
me a little bit of weight so that I can
make sure they're not going to totally
slip. I do have a little bit of chocolate,
my hands too. Okay. From here? Yeah,
she's putting her hands on my thighs
stepping up, my arms are straight.
I'm pushing a bit with the fingertips
and then she's going to do a progression
straddle
and then you can do any number
of different things. Okay.
So that would be from pipe position.
If she did a Tuck,
that'd be a little bit easier.
And then you can also do straddle work.
So there are many different ways to work
in this position to get more mileage
without totally destroying your joints.
If you're putting all of your weight.
And then you can do things like this,
which I can't do,
but sometimes flexi flyers
can get it done. Okay.
All right.
And the way this translates that position
that we just did is you want to do
bird to shoulder,
stand to helicopter.
So the way that translates as a base,
you're developing the skill
to do stuff like this.
Okay? So this is the
beginner's version. Uh,
and then if we wanted to do
the free standing version,
looks like that. And then you
can do all sorts of cool things.
Like we'd come up and rotate helicopter
and we can even go through it the second
time.
Like so
there you have it. If you enjoyed
that video, let's talk about a list.
Arnold Schwarzenegger, Jamie Foxx,
undisputed King of Big Wave Surfing.
Laird Hamilton. The list goes on
and on. What do they have in common?
They're sharing their secrets, their
morning routines, favorite books,
everything with me on my podcast, the Tim
Ferriss show, 70 million plus downloads,
iTunes, best of 2015 check it
out. You will not be disappointed.